all right wake up call or wake that's
the focus of tonight's
Angle now when the Border Bill Fiasco
was unraveling last night I started to
think about how the GOP Senate
leadership could so wildly misread their
own party on an issue as important as
this I mean do they ever listen to their
own constituents they ever read anything
about what the constituents believe any
polls don't they see that everyone is
fed up with double speak on the
border and then in I was thinking about
Trump's book you know the art of the
deal where he explains why PR alone like
the type you've been hearing about the
bill from people like Langford and
Cinema and Chris Murphy that that kind
of Bluster can't rescue a Bad final
product Trump wrote you can't con people
at least not for long you can create
excitement you can do wonderful
promotion and get all kinds of press and
you can throw in a little hyperbole but
if you don't deliver the goods people
will eventually catch on and that's what
happened here we told you weeks ago that
the phony border security bill being
cooked up in the Senate would be an
insult to your intelligence but they
kept saying that oh you're being unfair
you should just wait for the text well
of course by now every honest broker
knows that the actual text of the
bill scroll the prompter thank you text
the bill is much worse now as Speaker
Johnson said on this show last night it
wasn't even a border bill at all it was
really just an immigration Bill and a
liberal one at that because the Border
remains open unaccompanied miners don't
count toward the 5,000 person trigger
Millions still are allowed into the
country including through the ports of
entry and mayorcas retains the power to
Grant Asylum and remember Biden can end
the emergency for what he calls the
national interest and the Border
emergency itself sunsets in 3 years oh
and then money for a lawyer for migrants
of course Millions for that and it's a
huge Boon to foreign workers so by late
last night they had already lost 22
Republican Senators and it was
effectively a dead deal now you all know
this because you've been watching I
tried to warn Senator Langford that he
was just setting himself up to for the
fall to be the Fall Guy but he wouldn't
listen but at least he found a new
friend it's been an extraordinary effort
by senator fford Murphy and Cinema the
result of all this hard work is a
bipartisan agreement that represents the
most Fair Humane reforms in our
immigration system in a long time please
trusting Biden and my orcus on a border
bill would be like trusting Jeffrey
Epstein at a senior
prom the bill wouldn't have stopped The
Invasion it would have simply
regularized the flow maybe Managed IT a
tiny bit better and then it would have
hamstrung Trump from implementing
implementing a true border enforcement
operation which he knows how to do and
by the way to add insult to injury it
would have given Biden a small political
escape hatch on the border issue itself
but why would any Republican ever agree
to that but now Joe all he has in his
quiver magga bad all indications are
this bill won't even move forward to the
senate floor why a simple reason Donald
Trump because Donald Trump thinks it's
bad for him politically therefore he
doesn't even though it help the country
he's not for it he'd rather weaponize
this issue than actually solve it no the
truth is and I'm sure even Biden of the
addled mind knows it Trump did largely
have the Border solved this is just one
of dozens of substantive reasons that
noan conservative could ever have voted
for this and now that it's effectively
crashed and burned
the Democrats are following their little
consultant drafted battle plan it's a
hard pivot you're seeing it play out to
blame Biden's border catastrophe on
Trump we're going to have to carry this
message into November that the Democrats
have actually stood for fixing our
border and the Republicans have been
completely missing an action what did
Senator Bennett say uh Missing an action
Republicans missing an action on the
border
now how often has our borders Zar
visited the Border again do you have any
plans to visit the
Border I I'm here in Guatemala today I
at some point you
know we are going to The Border we've
been to the border so this whole this
whole this whole thing about the Border
we've been to the Border we've been to
the Border you haven't been to the
Border I and I haven't been to Europe
and Ian I don't I don't understand the
point that you're making I'm not
discounting the importance of the
border now the moment we heard that she
was put in charge of the Border was the
moment we knew that they plan to
overwhelm our country with migrants or
and they're thinking future Democrat
voters now as we painstakingly have
cataloged all their border dereliction
even Democrats started speaking
up I said it last year when we had
15,000 I'm telling you now what
110,000 the city we
knew we're about to lose as buses
continue to arrive in the city of
Chicago and all over the country the
type of chaos that has been administered
has left many of our local
economies under tremendous amount of
duress looks like a hostage tape there
now we all feel the growing power of the
cartels the criminal gangs the Chinese
the north Africans the middle easterners
who are coming here by the hundreds of
thousands that ain't mag's fault it's
all on Biden and my orcus and none of it
was an accident they're achieving their
goals here as I said with Chad pergram
if a phone called to zinski is an
impeachable offense then what Biden has
done to the Border Darnell has to be the
vast property damage they've caused all
the greenia ACs it's been an
environmental catastrophe think about
every innocent American brutalized by
migrant crime every child who's been
trafficked and abused every woman raped
along the way including a lot of the
migrants every dollar spent on migrants
that could be spent on our own veterans
and our own
homeless but somehow Biden thinks voters
in November are going to take it out on
Trump because Republicans said no to
defending other countries when the
Senate couldn't agree to defend
America folks we've got to move past
this talk
politics it's time to stop playing games
with the world waiting and watching and
by the way the world is waiting the
world is watching they are waiting and
watching what we're going to do we can't
let we can't continue to let Petty
partisan politics get in the way of our
responsibility Petty partisan politics
translation conservatives decided they
wouldn't be rolled again and hyperbole
about Putin that's not going to change a
single voter's mind
this bill is standing up to Putin
opposing this bill is playing into his
hands as I said before the stakes on
this fight extend well beyond Ukraine if
we don't stop Putin's appetite for power
and controlling Ukraine he won't limit
himself to just Ukraine okay none of
this makes any sense because if the unip
party really wanted all that money for
Ukraine and it's a lot of money or they
want something for the dreamers or
foreign worker say whatever they want
they needed to bargain with something
real not offer some fake border bill
that impowered mayorcas and neutered a
future president Trump the days of heavy
footing the populace are over unless
something wild happens Trump's going to
be the party's nominee in November for
the third presidential election in a row
get the hen everybody everybody's got to
get used to that reality this is not the
party of Mitt Romney or Liz Cheney and
if Trump does win the deals that come
out of his administration will actually
be good for the American people first
real negotiations with real results by
including all the key players the Senate
unit party tried their border sneak and
they failed miserably this will either
be a wake-up call for them or their
political wake hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our modest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else